I didn't do want to do another Knight
Rider that Knight Rider was and is a
legendary show but at that point Knight
Rider was looked at as as fluff and it
was cancelled at NBC
unfortunately because it wasn't like
Hill Street Blues or friends or you know
or hip or cool it was something that
appealed to middle America
something that appealed to the children
we had fantastic ratings and it was
almost with apologies of Brandon
Tartikoff who was the brilliant mind
behind NBC at that time and brought us
Hill Street Blues and but changed the
network he was only 32 he came around
and almost apologetically canceled the
show and said well you know we're not
gonna make it with then we went and so a
few years later grant tinker who was the
CEO of NBC later went off to become a
producer and produced Baywatch and
produced a ill-fated show called USA
Today which was a TV show about the USA
Today a newspaper and and when when I
first saw Baywatch I thought do I really
want to do another show like this it
they showed me the the sizzle reel which
was rescue guys in slow motion on the
beach and incredibly beautiful stuff and
I had a hit looking for freedom in
Germany and I said well I don't
understand why would I want to go back
and do this this show that's not that
cool when I'm doing looking for freedom
and and suddenly I would became this
huge rock star in Germany so I played
looking for freedom for grant and played
and walked around the office and then
they showed me the sizzle reel so I
called my manager Jim McCormick and I
said it's a lot like Baywatch
I really don't want to do it but it's
gonna be a huge hit
get it tell no but get it
so she said no and we said no about ten
times until we got the right fee and
then we said yes and we went back and we
did it then the show was cancelled after
the first year on NBC with the exact
same ratings as Knight Rider because I
don't think it was cool it was appealed
to middle America so we found out that
it was so successful in all of Europe
that I was approached by a guy named
Paul Talbot who was the owner and sole
owner of Fremantle at that point and
Paul came to me and said look and the
rest of the crew and the rest of the
producers we can sell this show overseas
Hasselhoff is so big overseas with
Knight Rider and we're looking for
freedom we can get half the financing
from overseas why don't we get half the
financing and move it from NBC and put
it on a smaller Channel a syndicated
channel a local channel like I don't
know what the local channel is here but
in America will be channel 9 it would be
channel 5 be channel 13 so we went and
we did and I went to Germany and the
Germans said can you bring us more
tonight right off and I said no I can't
they said it's been canceled yeah but I
said I have a new show does it have a
car and I said no it doesn't have a car
are you in it yes and it has the same
values as Knight Rider it's about saving
lives
it's basically Michael Knight running
down the beach in a bathing suit with
beautiful women saving lives in the
ocean no car I said no there's no car
but you're in it I said yes okay we bye
anyway that was the conversation and we
raised $425,000 at that point for North
America and Europe and so they took
North America and Europe we took the
rest of the world so when we came back
to LA we had 400 25,000 well the show
cost a million 1 million two so we
figured out how to make the
around eight eight seventy something
like eight hundred seventy and we raised
the rest of the money by going around to
local channels and the advertising
agencies and we nickel and dimed our way
to the first season and blasted eleven
seasons two hundred and forty-five
episodes and was in the Guinness Book of
World Records this the number one watch
show on the planet
so we did something right because we saw
the opportunity and we saw the people
liked it it wasn't the same thing with
Knight Rider people made fun of Knight
Rider but we were and we were up against
Dallas so I went out and did all those
car shows where you sign on the grass
meet David Hasselhoff and the Knight
Rider car and KITT I did 75 the first
two years we beat Dallas we and we ended
up coming in second to Dallas which was
actually at that point we were the first
show in 26 years to not get cancelled
against Dallas and so Knight Rider led
the way and then Baywatch led the way
and then we personally just led the way
because of my success in Europe was
looking for freedom and Knight Rider and
Baywatch now is is still loved all over
the world as well as Knight Rider so
it's amazing you know the shows that
I've been doing they're not like the
real super hip dark shows they're the
shows that appeal to families kids you
know I would say 7 to 17 loved Knight
Rider loved Baywatch when they grew up
and they still loved it I hear about
Knight Rider every single day and right
now we're in development with company I
can't really talk about to do Knight
Rider of the movie as a huge franchise
and bring back the Knight Rider the way
it should be brought back which is a
continuation of the show and not like a
new car a new person they tried that it
didn't work at all so we're going to
continue it I'm going to be involved
and maybe maybe behind the car for a
little bit and we'll see what happens